hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of entrepreneur mastery
today we're going to talk about how you
can get over your fears and get started
one of the things I really like to do is
look at the stories of famous
entrepreneurs it really inspires me and
I like to learn their lessons for
success I believe the success leave
clues and if you look at enough famous
entrepreneurs you'll get some ideas for
how you can grow your business one of
the things I've learned from researching
famous entrepreneurs is that they come
from all sorts of different backgrounds
some of them are wealthy when they start
most of them had nothing when they
started some of them are Type A
personalities love to be out selling a
lot of them are introverts and they
don't like selling but one of the things
that they all have in common was that
they got started they took an idea for a
business and they made it into reality
they overcame the fears that they had
just get started and they took action so
today I want to talk about eight ways
that you can conquer your fears
you